[تصفيق]
شكراً جزيلاً لكم اليوم ،
لقد اتخذت إسرائيل خطوة كبيرة نحو السلام.
الشباب في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط
مستعدون لمستقبل أكثر تفاؤلاً
والحكومات في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
تدرك أن الإرهاب والتطرف الإسلامي
هما العدو المشترك للجميع
بالأمس.  من دواعي سروري
لقاء كل من رئيس وزراء إسرائيل
ورجل يعمل بجد
ليصبح الطريقة الأساسية خادمًا
وأطول انتخابات على الإطلاق
رهان ضد الحزب الأزرق والأبيض
وانضم إلي كلا الزعيمين للتعبير
عن دعمهما  من أجل هذا الجهد
الذي يثبت أن دولة إسرائيل تبحث عن
السلام وأن السلام يتجاوز
السياسة بأي مقياس لا يمكن قياسه ، هذا ما
يريدونه
في رحلتي الأولى إلى الخارج كرئيسة
زرت الأراضي المقدسة في إسرائيل ، لقد
تأثرت بشدة وأذهلتني ما
امتلكته الدولة الصغيرة  تحققت في
وجه الصعاب الهائلة والتهديدات التي لا تنتهي ،
فإن دولة إسرائيل
لا تضم سوى مساحة صغيرة من الأرض  في
الشرق الأوسط ومع ذلك أصبحت
مركزًا مزدهرًا لثقافة الابتكار
والديمقراطية والتجارة ، فإن إسرائيل هي نور
للعالم تتشابك قلوب وتاريخ
شعبنا معًا ،
أرض إسرائيل هي منزل قديم
مكان عبادة مقدس وهم  وعد
رسمي للشعب اليهودي بأننا لن
نكرر أبدًا أحلك ساعة في التاريخ
خلال رحلتي إلى إسرائيل ، التقيت أيضًا
بفلسطينيين